Oh
so one of the things that would be
really useful to have I think is an
operating manual for human beings like
literally if we could figure out a set
of instructions a set of algorithms that
would teach us how to optimize ourselves
how to tweak the knobs and levers of
consciousness towards useful spaces of
contemplation and transformation so that
we may become more than what we are so
that we may expand transcend transform
and there's a wonderful idea
popularized by Kevin Kelly known as
finite and infinite games now finite and
infinite games is a book by religious
scholar James P cars and Kevin Kelley
who co-founded Wired magazine has
praised it for altering my thinking
about life the universe and everything
and essentially it comes down to this
finite games are played to win or lose
right that's familiar that's boring
infinite games are played to keep a game
going take note of this idea it is no
longer about black and white it is no
longer about winning or losing the cool
here is to keep the game going to reach
a kind of cosmic homeostasis to move to
spaces beyond entropy beyond death it's
not about conquering it's about
continuing to exist to contemplate it's
about immortalizing and eternal izing
it's consciousness you know the futurist
Ray Kurzweil has popularized the term
singularity as the moments in which
humans transcend biology the Jesuit
scholar Pierre de Chardin talks about
the omega point and the directionality
of evolution you know others have
written about the fact that we've
decommissioned natural selection and now
we get to look deep within ourselves and
actually decide author what would wish
to become we are a geologic force now
we've seen how this power can be used in
destructive ways we've seen the effects
of global warming
but we must also realize that we have
any capacity with these new construction
kits for our reality to not just address
the Grand Challenges of humanity but
essentially to fix the world not to win
or lose but to keep the game going so
let us say this right let us stop
playing the finite game let us play the
infinite game